(Sirens blaring)
- [Interviewer] Where
are you from originally?
- I'm originally from Texas born in Texas.
I was raised in Arizona.
I got brought to California
by a pimp when I was 18.
- [Interviewer] You got what?
- Brought to California
by a pimp when I was 18.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- But I've been with
the pimp since I was 14.
We've been all over Vegas, Utah
back to Arizona, Washington
and then here.
I came here when I was 18.
We had this other girl that came
out here with us from
Washington and she lied
about her age and the police,
when they picked her up
she told him that he forced her out here.
And then, so he locked him up
and then I got left out here
and I didn't have no family.
My family kind of like disowned me because
I chose to hang out with black people.
And so like, I've been
on the streets since.
My, it's been hard, tryin
to make it out here.
- [Interviewer] How long
you been on the street?
- I been on the streets since I was 14.
- [Interviewer] Hm.
- Yeah.
- I ended up having kids.
My daughter, when I met her dad
I actually got clean for like two years.
And then I stopped prostituting.
And then when I had my
daughter he started beating me
and stuff, and then I had to leave him.
So I went back to the streets
and then I met my babies, my boys, dad
and then he-
basically had me prostituting
when I was pregnant.
(laughs)
He didn't a give a fuck about me.
Tryin to survive.
You know, had my baby
at seven months pregnant
his brother got custody of him.
And then I got pregnant again.
And the second one,
the dad's brother's wife's
best friend got my other son.
- [Interviewer] How many
children do you have?
- Three.
- [Interviewer] Three?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you see any of them?
- I see my daughter whenever I want
but my two boys, no.
I wish I could, but no.
- [Interviewer] And now you're
living on the street here.
- Yeah. I'm stayin' on Stafford and 7th.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
right around the corner.
- Yeah, in a tent. See the tent.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And you're still
picking up guys to make money?
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I got this trig beat me up last night.
- [Interviewer] What'd he do, hit you?
- Yeah. And threw me on the ground.
And he was like trying
to drag me on the ground.
Well, because he
- [Cameraman] Can we see it- (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Yeah, it's from dragging me and then,
He, because he wanted his money back.
Well, he had his nut,
but he nutted too fast.
So he wanted his money back.
And then I was like, you can't do that.
You can't, you know, it's not my fault
that you came fast, you
know, but I mean, shit.
But it's hard out here trying to survive.
- [Interviewer] How much money
does a guy pay you when he picks you up?
Typically.
- He gave me $40 for some head, and then
because he came too fast, it was like,
he wanted his money back and I'm like
it don't work like that, you
still got what you wanted.
But then I wasn't gonna
give him his money back
so he started to fighting with me
and then he started dragging me and shit
And I mean, it defeated the whole purpose
cause he still didn't get his money.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Hm.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what's your drug?
Here on the street.
- I use heroin and
PCP.
- [Interviewer] At what age
did you start doing drugs?
- When I started
prostituting, the pimp got me.
He got me smoking crack.
And then-
- [Interviewer] That was 18?
- No, I was 14 when I
started smoking crack.
- [Interviewer] 14? Oh.
- Yeah, because it was from 14 to 18-
- [Interviewer] So at 14 you
were working as a prostitute.
- Yeah, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk with your family,
your parents, your mom?
- My mom passed away.
My dad's a sex offender,
so I don't talk to him.
I don't have another family,
I mean, besides my kids, I don't what-
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- My dad's a child molester.
My dad molested me.
My sister.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- He molested me from
the age of 5 til I was 6.
He molested my sister from,
I think from 6 until she was
13.
- [Interviewer] Where is she now?
- I don't know. She ran
off when she was 14.
Haven't seen her since.
- [Interviewer] And your mom
didn't know this was going on?
- At first, she didn't.
But then, like, she found out
because my sister told her
and then my mom didn't believe her.
And then,
well, my dad ended up kidnapping
me and my brother took us out of state.
And-
when he had us, he had us for
like six months in Mexico.
And then when he, when my
mom didn't get us back,
my brother and me told
her what he was doing.
What he did to me and stuff.
And she took me to the hos-
Well, of course he took me
to the hospital and stuff,
and he got put away.
I had a fucked up childhood.
- [Interviewer] Hm.
Where would you like to
see yourself in five years?
- I'd like to see myself back in school.
Have an apartment,
so I can at least have my daughter,
you know, stay the nights with me.
I don't know.
Just want better.
(Sirens blaring)
- [Interviewer] How often do you get run
into violent guys that pick you up?
- Well, it depends.
(Sirens blaring)
Sometimes,
I don't know, it just depends, really.
But recently it's kind
of like been like shitty
and like even the police,
be sittin there making us
you know, turns date with them.
And then if we don't turn a date with em,
they sit there and fuckin
threaten to take us to jail.
And then, of course we give
it to em, so they let us go.
But,
even that, they don't make it any better.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's rough out here, hm?
- Uh huh.
(car horn honks)
- [Interviewer] Well, thank
you for talking to me,
- [Christie] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] and sharing your story.
- [Christie] Mhm.
(laughs)
Probably sounds like everybody else's.
- [Interviewer] Good
luck out there. Be safe.
- All right, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Mhm.